auch Geschichtsdeutung die er da hat und
er hat das heute damit verglichen weil
ich glaube er selber verstanden hat dass
es hier gerade ums Ganze geht das war
uns allen gestern Abend noch nicht so
klar und heute morgen noch nicht so klar
aber mit jeder Stunde wird es deutlicher
dass ich in dieser Situation im Moment
auch das Schicksal Putin sogar
entscheiden könnte und ich glaube ihm
selber ist das sehr wohl bewusst in der
Rock war das aus Moskau ich sage vielen
Dank für diese Analysen
also offenbar geht es jetzt für Vladimir
Putin jedenfalls für sein Russland
hinter seiner Führung ums ganze fragen
wir nach in Kiew was das für die Ukraine
bedeuten könnte Darko jakobjevic ist uns
zugeschaltet von dort wie sieht denn die
ukrainische Regierung die Entwicklung in
Russland
Präsident selinski sieht das als eine
Führungsschwäche in Russland bewertet
dies als ein ja komplettes Chaos was da
jetzt gerade in Russland passiert und
die Frage die dahinter steht und die
auch am meisten jetzt Präsident selenski
auch beschäftigt ist welche Vorteile
kann die Ukraine daraus ziehen aus
diesen dramatischen Entwicklungen in
Russland ja und was glaubt man welche
Vorteile kann man daraus ziehen die Vize
verteilungsministerin sprach ja von
einer Zitat einmaligen Gelegenheit für
Kia was meint sie denn damit
ganz klar militärischen Profit daraus zu
schlagen und die die Idee dahinter ist
auch also dass man genau anschauen wird
was passiert jetzt an der Frontlinie in
der Ukraine man glaubt auch dass sich
das auf die Kampfmoral der russischen
Truppen auswirken könnte und dieser
psychologische Faktor der ist auch nicht
zu unterschätzen andererseits fakt ist
dass ich es momentan an der Front an dem
besetzten Gebieten wo die russischen
Truppen ja sind dass ich sehr gut
verschanzt haben und dass wir da
momentan überhaupt keine Anzeichen sehen
für Absetzbewegungen irgendeine Flucht
oder gar irgendeine Panik man ist ja
prigosh ihn ein Kriegsverbrecher und
einen Mörder aber er hält ja wohl diesen
Krieg im Kern für sinnlos das hat er ja
wieder heute zum Ausdruck gebracht was
geschieht denn wenn er mit diesem
Aufstand scheitert muss dann die Ukraine
Ukraine damit rechnen dass sich die
Befürworter einer noch härteren
Kriegsführung dann durchsetzen
also ich denke es heißt erst einmal
nichts Gutes für die Ukraine weil jeden
ist klar der Krieg der würde erst einmal
so weitergehen wie sie es auch letzte
Nacht hier in Kiew auch erlebt haben es
gab ja wieder reguläre muss man sagen
Luftangriffe auf die Stadt Kiew es gab
mindestens drei Tote und drehen wir mal
diesen Gedanken um von prigoshi also
wenn er halt irgendwie sagt dass es
sinnlos gewesen sei ja ähm er hat auch
gleichzeitig gesagt dass er auch
weitergehen würde mit dem Krieg gegen
die Ukraine also man müsse halt so Pre
Goschen so verstehe ich ihn erst einmal
Russland von ihnen befreien und dann
weiter die Ukraine befreien so die Worte
so das Statement von Goshi heute und das
heißt eigentlich für die Ukraine nichts
Gutes weil der Krieg eigentlich
weitergehen würde vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzung danke nach Kiel
also möglicherweise wird sich für die
Ukraine an den Kampfhandlungen zunächst
nichts ändern nach wie vor schwere
Angriffe auch in den letzten 24 Stunden
auf die Ukraine und auch auf Kiew
allerdings die Situation in Russland
kann kein Mensch einschätzen kein Mensch
weiß wie es dort weitergehen wird da
bleibt natürlich die Sorge was ist mit
den vielen Atomraketen in Russland was
ist wenn die in die Hand von Leuten
kommt die damit möglicherweise radikaler
vorgehen wollen als die bisherige
Führung in Moskau diese Sorge treibt
natürlich viele auch in Berlin an
beobachten das einzige was man in
Deutschland offenbar derzeit tun kann am
Rande des spd-parteitages in
Niedersachsen gibt der
Bundesverteidigungsminister zu man sei
überrascht worden von den Vorgängen in
Russland
damit hat glaube ich niemand gerechnet
jedenfalls noch nicht so muss man sagen
die Entwicklung sind jetzt werden gerade
aktuell beobachtet und analysiert wir
werden heute noch einige Lagen dazu
haben auch der Kanzler lassen sich
laufend informieren heißt es von einem
Regierungssprecher mein koordiniere sich
mit den Ängsten Verbündeten die
bundesaußenministerin Waren per Twitter
deutsche Staatsangehörige in Russland
sollten die angepassten
Sicherheitshinweise beachten so soll das
Stadtzentrum in Moskau unbedingt
gemieden werden die Union mannt die
bisherige Zurückhaltung beizubehalten
wieder zwei Fronten das ist jetzt ein
inneres Schicksal Russlands und wir
sollten die Ukraine unterstützen dass
sie die militärische Chance die für sie
daraus erwächst auch ergreifen kann aus
der linken dagegen die Forderung die
Chance zu ergreifen und Gespräche mit
Russland zu führen
ich bin dafür so schnell wie möglich
einen Waffenstillstand zu machen damit
wenigstens das Töten verletzen und
zerstören aufhören in Berlin wird es im
Laufe des Tages noch einige
Krisentreffen geben dort heißt es
abwarten die deutsche Politik blickt
gespannt Richtung Russland
und auch wir blicken gespannt auf die
Entwicklung in Russland Joachim Weber
ist bei uns im Studio der
Sicherheitsexperte schönen guten Abend
bei Phoenix der verteilungsminister sagt
er wäre durchaus überrascht gewesen von
dieser Entwicklung sie auch Erwerber
naja es ist immer überraschend wenn es
dann passiert nicht aber dass das
irgendwann passieren würde habe ich
schon erwartet aber vielleicht jetzt
noch nicht in diesem Moment und so
plötzlich aber das ist immer das
Überraschungsmoment das solchen Dingen
innewohnt es war seit Monaten eigentlich
zu sehen dass ich da ein innerer
russischer Machtkampf zuspitzt seit
mehreren Wochen hat Putin ähm nein
umgekehrt hat brigosin Äußerungen getan
wo ich immer wieder gedacht habe das
kann doch Putin nicht mehr
unwidersprochen jetzt hinnehmen ohne
sozusagen da reinzugeräten und
offenkundig war es doch so weit gedient
es ist ja auch vieles davon immer wieder
an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen auch
bewusst von der wagnergruppe in der
Öffentlichkeit ausgetragen worden jetzt
war wohl das Maß voll jetzt bereitet
sich im Moskau obwohl darauf vor
gasbrigoschin und seine wagnertruppe
demnächst in Moskau sein werden wir
haben gesehen vorhin auf den Ringen
werden schon LKWs geparkt mit Sandsäcken
um möglicherweise das weitere vorrücken
aufzuhalten der traut sich was zu der
brückershin oder wie stark ist der genau
das ist das was schwer einzuschätzen ist
seine Truppe soll ja bis zu 50.000 Mann
insgesamt umfassen wie viel davon
kurzfristig von A nach B nach C
transportiert werden können wie stark
Sie im Moment wirklich aktuell ist das
entzieht sich im Grunde unsere
Einsichtnahme aber es werden etliche
tausend bewaffnete sein die hier
kommandiert und die ihm bedingungslos
loyal und ergeben sind ihm gegenüber und
die bereit sind auch für sich also die
Leute fürchten den Tod nicht das glaube
ich ist auf dem kundig geworden auch in
diesen ganzen kämpfen und bachmut und
überall das heißt die werfen sich da in
die Bresche für ihn und die marschieren
mit Druck und mit Nachdruck Richtung
Moskau wir haben hier im Hintergrund die
Karte die können wir uns vielleicht noch
mal im Vollbild genau genauer anschauen
also Rostov am Don ist das Ganze
gestartet und weit der ukrainischen
Grenze dachten danach Woronesch und
jetzt ist man mittlerweile schon in
lippets angekommen es ist rund 450 km
nur noch von Moskau entfernt können Sie
sich vorstellen dass tatsächlich das
Ziel von brigoschen ist wie es hier im
Internet heißt dass er Moskau umzingeln
will um dann eventuell zu verhandeln
oder was ist ein militärisches Ziel wird
der Moskau nicht können dafür werden
seine Kräfte nicht reichen dafür ist die
Stadt auch viel zu groß die Zeit wird
man auch nicht haben also diese Dinge
kumulieren jetzt hier in einem
unglaublichen Tempo wenn man sich wir
haben sie eben auf der Karte gesehen
anschauen wie weit Rostock am donnern
entfernt ist und jetzt haben sie schon
fast zwei Drittel des Weges zurückgelegt
an der Tag ist noch nicht mal mal um und
wir sprechen über hunderte von
Kilometern also man hat jetzt hier Druck
auf den Reifen nicht und man fährt und
höchstens militärische Gewalt kann die
noch aufhalten da werden auch keine
keine Laster oder irgendwas daran ändern
aber es soll ja auch Luftangriffe
gegeben haben auf die Kolonne
offenkundiger zumindest ein Teil der
russischen Streitkräfte loyal gegenüber
den Präsidenten Teil ist so übergelaufen
jedenfalls wird es im Internet
geschrieben muss man ja präziserweise
dazu sagen jetzt haben sie gesagt dieser
Machtkampf der dauert schon länger an
wer ist das nur Scheu gegen brigochian
oder wer tritt dagegen anders ich glaube
nicht dass ursprünglich Schuhe unbedingt
den entschuldigung das brigochien
unbedingt den Machtkampf mit Putin
gesucht hat der der Macht gar nicht
Entschuldigung den privaten Versager
hält der von Militär keine Ahnung hat
und und glücklos agiert dieser Eindruck
ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht ganz
falsch aber das ist eine Situation die
besteht schon von lange er hat
wahrscheinlich lange gehofft er hat
gregorien dass er nicht unbedingt gegen
Putin vorgehen muss aber es hat sich
dann so ergeben dass Putin einfach am
schulgut Lager und und und seiner
Führungsriege da festhält und dieser
immer mehr aus russischer Sicht eben
schief laufende Krieg natürlich auch den
handlungs auf die russische Seite erhöht
und irgendwann war jetzt das Maß voll ob
es wirklich diese Luft Angriffe ich höre
mal von Luftangriffen mal von
Raketenbeschuss auf diese Wagner Lager
gegeben habe oder ob die Ukrainer dann
im Heimat hingeflankt haben und man
schiebt sie jetzt tschuldigung die
Schuhe das wissen wir alles nicht so
Stunde
gewesen zu sein jedenfalls für Putin der
spricht in seiner Fernsehansprache heute
von Verrat damit ist klar er lässt sich
auf jeden Fall oder ja natürlich da ist
das ist vollkommen zerschnitten dieses
Tischtuch es kann nur davon ausgehen
dass einer sozusagen da liegend
herausgetragen wird aus diesem Zweikampf
da gibt's keinen zurück mehr nicht es
wäre wer sich gegen die Staatsgewalt mit
militärischer Macht und und all diesen
auflehnt in Russland der ist entweder
ein toter Mann oder er sieht also nur
diese zwei Möglichkeiten gibt da weiß
man von dem Mann im Kreml das eine
Horror Angst davor hat schon lange davon
hat dass es ihm mal so geht wie er darf
sie eines Tages der ja aus diesem
Erdloch gezogen worden ist dann getötet
worden ist davor hat wohl Putin schon
sehr lange Angst gehabt möglicherweise
ist die Angst jetzt berechtigt vielen
Dank bis hierhin aber wir reden gleich
weiter wir wollen schauen auf noch mal
etwas ausführlicher auf die Reaktion des
verteilungsministers Pistorius der ja
wie gesagt in dem kurzen Ausschnitt
vorher schon erläutert hat er war
überrascht
nein damit hat glaube ich niemand
gerechnet jedenfalls noch nicht so muss
man sagen die Entwicklung sind jetzt
werden gerade aktuell beobachtet und
analysiert wir werden heute noch einige
Lagen dazu haben ist auf jeden Fall zu
früh das jetzt zu bewerten was bedeutet
ein instabiles Russland für den
ukrainekrieg das lässt sich schwer
abschätzen zumal wenn ich wissen wie
instabil Russland werden wird und wir am
Ende die Oberhand behält und wer sich
mit wem zusammentut ist einfach zu früh
jetzt seine Bewertung abzugeben wenn man
das jetzt hätte würde man den offenen
Blick eintrüben für das was tatsächlich
passiert deswegen halte ich mich da
selber zurückbringen
in dieser Situation gibt es für uns
keine Handlungsoption das ist ein
innenpolitischer Konflikt in Russland ob
der sich zu einem Machtkampf entwickelt
das können wir noch nicht sagen wir sind
Beobachter wir beobachten genauso wie
alle anderen Verbündeten sehr aufmerksam
und behalten unser Augenmerk ansonsten
auf die Unterstützung der Ukraine
gerichtet jetzt auf deutscher Seite
Krisensitzung geben dazu heute
vielleicht noch es gibt Lagebesprechung
dazu wir zukunftsaustauschen über die
Erkenntnisse die vorliegen das wird
heute oder im Laufe des Wochenendes
weiter passieren
bislang nicht nein
ukrainische Regierung setzt darauf dass
sich Deutschland an da internationalen
Beteiligungen mit Kampfjets auch
beteiligt die sich damit aus das habe
ich schon so oft gesagt dass es gibt
eine F16 Koalition das ist richtig und
gut die wird sich auf den Weg machen
aber auch die braucht eine Zeit eine
schnelle hilfe ist nicht in den nächsten
Wochen zu erreichen weil Ausbildung
erfolgen muss es muss die Instandsetzung
die Logistik vorbereitet werden das ist
nichts was man mal eben in wenigen Tagen
macht aber das ist Sache dieser
Koalition in der sind wir nicht drin
weil wir keine F16 Kampfjets haben wir
sind die Experten für Panzerlieferungen
und panzertechnologie gewesen sind es
für die Luftverteidigung die nach wie
vor von enormer Bedeutung ist an dieser
Stelle sind wir nicht in erster Reihe ja
so viel der vom verteilungsminister
heute zur aktuellen Situation in
Russland rigoschin und seine Wagner
Söldner es heißt 25 bis 50.000 Mann sind
wohl unterwegs Richtung Moskau wie das
enden wird das weiß kein Mensch zu sagen
möglicherweise kommt es ja dann um einen
Kampf um Moskau wie das ausgeht das weiß
man nicht was man allerdings weiß ist
dass diese sogenannte wagnertruppe also
pregorsche ins Privatarmee Kampf
erfahren ist und da sind viele viele
Männer bei die tatsächlich bereit sind
in den Tod zu gehen
sie sind berüchtigt für ihre
Skrupellosigkeit nicht nur gegenüber dem
Feind sondern auch gegenüber der
Zivilbevölkerung und sogar den eigenen
Leuten die russische Söldnergruppe
Wagner sie wurde 2014 gegründet für den
Kampf in der Ostukraine
seitdem sollen wageneinheiten in etwa 30
Ländern im Einsatz gewesen sein unter
anderem in Syrien und Mali laut
britischen Geheimdienst befehle ich die
wagnergruppe bis zu 50.000 Kämpfer in
der Ukraine
rekrutiert werden vor allem ehemalige
russische Soldaten und zunehmend auch
Strafgefangene die dafür Amnestie halten
seit vergangenem Jahr tritt der
oligarchiv offiziell als Chef der
wagnergruppe auf
er galt als Freund und Vertrauter von
Präsident Putin äußerte aber immer
wieder laut Kritik an
verteilungsminister Scheu hier links im
Bild bezeichnete ihn als unfähig
während des ukrainekriegs kam es immer
wieder zu Spannungen zwischen den Wagner
söldenern und dem russischen Militär vor
knapp zwei Wochen hatte der
stellvertretende Verteidigungsminister
alle russischen Freiwilligenverbände
aufgefordert bis zum 1 Juli Verträge mit
seinem Ministerium zu unterzeichnen es
war auf mein Versuch die wagnergruppe in
das russische Militär zu integrieren und
somit besser zu kontrollieren privaten
erklärte damals dass er solche Verträge
nicht unterzeichnen werde und forderte
die Absetzung des verteilungsministers
und jetzt ist er unterwegs nach Moskau
mit seinen sollten wie gesagt bis zu
50.000 Mann wild entschlossen was
bedeutet das jetzt in dieser Situation
also die Frage ist was wirklich die
Situation in Moskau ist man bereitet
offenkundig die Verteidigung der Stadt
vor und es gibt ja Gerüchte um den
Präsidenten ist er überhaupt noch in
Moskau sollte er bereits aus Moskau
getürmt sein es gibt ja diese Stimmen
die sagen erst an seine fliegende
Kommandozentrale gesetzt worden hat sich
erstmal Richtung St Petersburg abgesetzt
wenn das wirklich wahr sein sollte wird
er sich allein von diesem Schlag wird
sich seine Herrschaft eigentlich gar
nicht mehr erholen können langfristig
auch wenn er vielleicht diesen Putsch
noch überstehen könnte wir wissen das ja
alles noch nicht das müssen wir jetzt
abwarten aber wenn er wirklich getürmt
ist nur weil diese Leute da 500 km an
Moskau herangekommen sind dann glaube
ich ist er so geschädigt sozusagen auch
in seinem Image dass das gar nicht mehr
wieder zu sanieren sein wird also er ist
ja überhaupt ein ein ängstlicher Mann
offenkundig nicht Mann
Dienstag gewesen und dementsprechend
auch aber möglicherweise ist jetzt
dieses Handeln hat ihn dieses Handeln in
eine Sackgasse geführt was man nicht
weiß ist wo er sich jetzt aufhält obwohl
der Regierungssprecher sagt
tatsächlich ist er in Moskau meistens
gilt ja das Gegenteil aber können wir
nicht überprüfen was wir aber wissen ist
dass kadyro auf dieser tschetschenische
Kämpfer der ja auch über eine
Privatarmee verfügt jetzt seine Truppen
tatsächlich Richtung Roßdorf an am Don
in Bewegung gesetzt hat und die sind
offenbar schon dort angekommen das
könnte jetzt tatsächlich auf einen Krieg
zwischen diesen Privatarmeen
hinauslaufen oder was würden Sie sagen
also dann kann die auch wirklich seine
Truppen nach Rostock für hinunterschickt
dann gibt das Schießerei dann ist
Russland im Bürgerkrieg es gibt ja
andere Meldungen die sagen die würden
jetzt noch Moskau gehen um dort zu
verteidigen aber das müsste eigentlich
die die Nationalgarde die ist also 2016
eigentlich extra aufgestellt worden und
Putin besser zu schützen hier das quadia
die sitzt damit tausenden von Mann und
müsste eigentlich in der Lage sein Ihren
Präsidenten in Moskau aber mit seinen
Leuten wirklich da einfliegt oder
runterfährt bis nach Rostock am Don
nicht dann wird er dort auf
entschlossene Wagner Kämpfer mhm treffen
die sagen mit dir tragen wir das auch
noch kurz aus also dann ist Russland
wirklich im Bürgerkrieg im Moment steht
man am Rande eines Bürgerkrieges mit
einem Bein noch draußen und mit einem
Bein drin würde ich sagen Stichwort
entschlossene Wagner Kämpfer Wagner hat
ja also brigoshi hat ja auch
Einheiten in Afrika im Einsatz vor allem
auch in Regionen wo Deutschland
eigentlich peacekeeping betreiben wollte
jetzt heißt es brigochien habe diese
wagner-kämpfer schon zurück beordert
wenn das denn stimmt was würde das denn
bedeuten ja es überschlagen sich ja
Meldungen aus allen Ecken und Regionen
und es wird dann am Ende der Tage zu
sortieren sein was davon wirklich wahr
ist aber wenn auch das stimmt dann
spricht das eher dafür dass das auch ein
paar Tage länger vielleicht geplant
worden ist ansonsten kommen die
wahrscheinlich zu spät aber wenn die da
bereits in den Flugzeugen sein sollten
oder auch schon eintreffen dann hat man
das wahrscheinlich doch ein bisschen
vorbereitet und versucht einfach Kräfte
zu bündeln und zusammenzuziehen um dem
Ganzen eine durchschlagen
dürfte er
kein Problem haben denn in Rostock am
donnern hat einen großen Flughafen der
jetzt in seiner Hand ist vielen Dank bis
hierhin wir wollen uns liebe Zuschauer
diesen noch mal etwas genauer anschauen
wir wollen es nämlich anschauen was er
heute früh ganz früh an diesem
Samstagmorgen gesagt hat zur Begründung
für seinen Einmarsch aus der Ukraine
jetzt nach Russland
wir befinden uns im Stab der sonder für
Operation ist der 7.30 unter unserer
Kontrolle sind alle militärko Objekte in
Rostow darunter auch der Flughafen da
leider die Militärflugzeuge die an der
Frontlinie im Einsatz sind setzen ihre
Arbeit fort sowie auch die
sanitätsflugzeuge das einzige was wir
gemacht haben also die Kontrolle
übernommen damit die Militärflugzeuge
nicht uns sondern die Ukraine angreifen
die
Leitungsorgane der Streitkräfte der
Arbeit sind wie gewohnt die jeder
Offizier ist am Arbeitsplatz und wir
stören die Arbeit der Stadt nicht und
als
als wir hierher gekommen sind sie
mussten wir feststellen er Norbert
Territorien sind verloren worden enorm
Menschen in Massen sind verloren worden
um mehrfach mehr als offiziell bekannt
gegeben wird die sanitätsverluster pro
Tag machen manchmal bis 1000 Menschen
aus das sind die getöteten die
Verwundeten und die Verweigerer es
mangelt an Munition und es mangelt an
der Leitung die Menschen sind in der
gastgasse der Chef des Stabs ist
geflogen worden sofort erfahren hat dass
wir uns dem Gebäude nähern ja das war so
brigochien jetzt kommt sein Gegenspieler
der macht aber im kremme Vladimir Putin
in einer 5-minütigen Fernsehansprache
heute Morgen nahm er zur Entwicklung
Erstellung also zu diesem Marsch auf
Moskau von Gosch ins Wagner sölln und
Vladimir Putin sprach darin wörtlich vom
Verrat und vom Durchstoß
ich wende mich an die Bürger Russlands
an die Truppen
an die
Rechtsschutzorgane und
Sicherheitsdienst der andere Kommandeure
und Kämpfe die gerade an der Front im
Einsatz sind
und wir die Helden machen ich weiß
darüber ganz genau heute Nacht zu habe
ich mit den allen Befehlshaber
gesprochen ich wende mich an diejenigen
die ihr durch die Lüge oder Betrug in
einer verbrecherische agenture
eingezogen sind und die auf den Weg die
haben Meuterei getreten sind heute steht
Russland im schweren Kampf für die
Zukunft sie werden Aggression der
Neonazis und ihrer Herren ab gegen uns
ist praktisch die ganze Maschinerie des
Westens Gerichten die Informationen die
Wirtschaft und die Sicherheits okay das
restens wir kämpfen für unsere
Souveränität und Unabhängigkeit für
unser Recht Russland zu sein und zu
bleiben Start mit dem mit der
1000-jährigen Geschichte und heute ist
natürlich die Einigkeit gibt gefragt die
Konsolidation und die solidarision
Solidarität heute müssen wir alles
beiseite legen die uns schwächt alle
Quelle leihen die von unseren
außenfeinden ausgenutzt werden um uns
von inneren so Schwächen deshalb alle
Verhandlungen die uns Schwächen das ist
eigentlich die Abtrünnigkeit von eigenem
Folge von Kameraden an der Front das ist
ein Stich in den Rücken gegen unser Volk
und unser Heimat genau so
kam es im Jahr 1917 als unser Land im
Weltkrieg stand und als Russland der sie
gestohlen worden wurde also der Verrat
führt
zum Zerfall der Staates und zum
Verzicht auf riesenterritorien und im
Endpunkt änderte sich alles im
Bürgerkrieg als die Brüder die Brüder
getötet haben und profitiert dafür haben
nur die ausländischen Feinde die unser
Land aufteilen wollten wir lassen das
nicht zu dass er sich wiederholt wir
werden unsere Heimat von allen Gefahren
verteidigen darunter von der
von dem inneren Vertrag das was wir
jetzt so tun haben das ist eben der
Verrat die
ausufernden
Ambitionen führten schon Verrat an dem
Volk und an den Kameraden an der
Frontlinien die Helden von
don't was untertürme auf konsolida die
Kämpfer von Wagner die ihr Leben
abgegeben haben im Kampf in der Ukraine
und dieser Menschen sind auch verraten
verraten worden von diejenigen die die
Menschen jetzt zur Treulosigkeit bewegen
noch mal jede
innerlicher wäre ist natürlich
gefährlich für uns als eine Nation das
ist ein gegen unser Volk und Nation und
unsere Handlungen zum Schutz der Nation
und der Heimat werden hart sein alle
diejenigen die bewusstlos die mörderei
vorbereitet haben durch die
terroristische Maßnahmen und die
auspresst und die Erpressung werden
sowohl vor dem Volk wie auch vor dem
Gesetz verantworten müssen die
Streitkräfte unter anderem Staatsorganen
Organe haben notwendige Befehle bekommen
die zusätzlichen Maßnahmen zur
sicherheitssicherung sind in Moskau in
Region Moskau sowie einen anderen
Regionen des Landes getroffen worden
zusätzliche Maßnahmen werden in Bezug
auf die Stadt Rostow am Donner getroffen
werden die Lage dort bleibt immer noch
kompliziert die Arbeit der zivil und
Militärbehörden sind dort blockiert
worden und als stadtprä Moment werde ich
alles tun um die Verfassungsordnung das
Leben und ihre Freiheit der Bürger in
Schutz zu nehmen die Organisatoren und
strecken sie ja der Meuterei diejenige
die die Waffe gegen die die Kameraden
gerichtet haben haben das Land für raten
und werden dafür verantwortlich müssen
die anderen Anrufe ich auf keinen
tragischen Fehler zu begehen und
einzig möglicher Entscheidung zu treffen
die Beteiligung an den gesetzwidrigen
Handlungen einzustellen ich bin fest
überzeugt wir werden unser Land
verteidigen wir werden alle
Herausforderungen meistern und werden
noch stärker
ja das war der russische Machthaber
Vladimir Putin heute Morgen um kurz nach
acht mit seiner aktuellen 5-minütigen
Ansprache ans russische Volk voller
dramatischer Aussagen die keinen Zweifel
daran lassen wie schwierig die Situation
für ihn ist also Russland möglicherweise
am Vorabend eines Bürgerkrieges das kann
den Nachbarn in der Europäischen Union
überhaupt nicht egal sein im Gegenteil
Berlin Brüssel Paris und sicher auch
London schauen mit Argusaugen auf diese
Entwicklung fahren wir nach in Brüssel
bei dem Kollegen Michael Grötz gibt es
schon irgendwelche Reaktionen aus
Brüssel Herr Grütz der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
jedenfalls war überrascht wie er sagt
über die Entwicklung war man das in
Brüssel auch
nun ich gehe mal davon aus dass das auch
für die Beteiligten hier und in den
Mitgliedstaaten der EU einigermaßen
überraschend kam dann hat man sich mehr
oder weniger auf einen
gleichlautenden
reaktionsmodus und Phrasen geeinigt und
der lautet dann wir beobachten die
Ereignisse in Russland genau und
ansonsten ist das eine innerrussische
Angelegenheit aber es ist natürlich wie
sie sagen mit nichten alleine so als
könnte das irgendwem hier egal sein ich
bin
glaube dass in vielen Hauptstädten wenn
ich in allen ähnliche Krisenstäbe getagt
haben oder noch Tagen sowie das sind
Berlin auch der Fall gewesen ist damit
man herausfindet welche Folgen kann
welche Konstellation auch immer haben
und im Prinzip ist ja immer noch etwas
gültig was die Briten heute morgen schon
äh gesagt haben als Reaktion die Pferde
zwischen
wagnergruppe und dem russischen
Verteidigungsministerium ist zu einer
regelrechten militärischen Konfrontation
es passiert und weiter hieß es in den
kommenden Stunden wird die Loyalität der
russischen Sicherheitskräfte und
insbesondere der russischen
Nationalgarde entscheidend für den
Verlauf der Krise sein das scheint immer
noch gültig zu sein wenngleich ist ja
einige Meldungen gibt dass da
prigoschin einfach durchfahren kann
Richtung Moskau und ohne großen
Widerstand ist also das aber als alles
unklar und insofern hat man sich hier
auf das Abwarten erstmal beschränkt
zumindest was die öffentlichen
Äußerungen angeht das ist ja eine
horror-vorstellung für viele Menschen in
Westeuropa aber sicher auf der ganzen
Welt dass diese vielen vielen Atom
springen Köpfe die Raketen der Russen in
die Hände von irgendwelchen Dören
geraten könnten ist das vielleicht ein
Szenario mit dem sich jetzt in dieser
aktuellen Situation auch die NATO in
Brüssel auseinandersetzen muss
also wir hatten ja vorher die Situation
dass bei ich bitte das nicht sarkastisch
oder ironisch zu verstehen dass das zwar
eine furchtbare Situation war mit der
Ukraine und dem Angriffskrieg aber hier
schien man sich relativ sicher zu sein
dass eine Eskalation in Sachen Atom so
ohne weiteres da nicht möglich ist wenn
gleich die Sorge natürlich immer da ist
mit diesem was wir heute erleben hat
sich natürlich für die NATO für die
Mitgliedstaaten die Situation gravieren
verändert mit dem Unterschied dass man
überhaupt nicht weiß wie es weitergeht
und mit wem ist dann irgendwann
weitergehen könnte und deswegen
natürlich spielt das eine eine große
Rolle die NATO das muss man vielleicht
dazu sagen hält sich bei solchen
Fragestellungen zurück man will auf gar
keinen Fall den Eindruck erwecken dass
das hier eine Auseinandersetzung ist
zwischen NATO und Russland wenn es um
den Krieg Russland gegen die Ukraine
geht das ist Sache der Mitgliedstaaten
und so sagt man eben auch jetzt das ist
sein inner russischer Konflikte muss
dort gelöst werden also allen halben er
gibt es überall noch diese Zurückhaltung
der einzelnen
EU-Chefs sie werden sich sicher aber
zusammen tun sie haben sich heute schon
zusammengetan und werden das auch weiter
tun während verschiedene Fachbereiche in
den außen nun Verteidigungsministerien
analysieren werden welche Szenario kommt
wann möglicherweise und womit muss man
im Zweifelsfall dann rechnen Michael
groß war das aus Brüssel vielen Dank für
Ihre Zeit und danke für diese
Erläuterungen Joachim Weber der
Sicherheitsexperte ist nach wie vor bei
uns im Studio wir haben ja vorhin
Wladimir Putin in den Machthaber gehört
mit sehr eindringlichen Worten hat er
noch mehr noch mal vom Durchstoß von
Verrat gesprochen herr Weber das ist
jetzt ein ganz anderer Putin der über
den möglichen Bürgerkrieg im eigenen
Land redet als den Putin den wir immer
gehört haben zum
Vernichtungskrieg den er ja gegen die
Ukraine führt oder ja in der Tat in der
spricht von einem tödlichen Kampf in
Russland verstrickt ist aber im Grunde
ist er und sein Regime ein tödlichen
Kampf strikt es geht jetzt auch für ihn
und seinen Regime alle die das Regime
tragen um alles das muss man sich in
aller Klarheit noch mal deutlich machen
und sie sagen zu Recht wenn wir jetzt
noch mal die 15 16 Monate zurückgehen da
beginnt man eine wie man glaubt
begrenzte
militär-spezialoperation gegen die
Ukraine um dieses Land in irgendeiner
Weise zu unterwerfen und es interessiert
fast niemanden in Russland ja es ist
etwas was man abends in den Nachrichten
sieht aber man denkt man hat damit
nichts zu tun und jetzt kämpft das
Moskau Regime die Regierung in Moskau
und das eigene Überleben weil russische
Kräfte auf Moskau marschieren nicht etwa
ukrainische russische Kräfte auf Moskau
marschieren und die Regierung abzulösen
und in China ist alles stabil also ist
eine eine unglaubliche Tragweite diese
Ereignis hier haben und es wird glaube
ich auch überall so gesehen und
verstanden das ist wirklich Weltpolitik
in Aktion ist immer noch so eine Art
Trauma für die Russen also dass der
panzer rollen und versuchen zu putzen
also ich meine die Eltern unter uns an
mich eingeschlossen haben ja die Bilder
von jetzt sehen damals auf dem Panzer
noch vor Augen ist es bis ist ja so eine
Art Trauma für die russische Führung
nein so weitgehend glaube ich ist das
vielleicht nicht einzuordnen aber wir
müssen schon erkennen es gibt in
Russland einen wiederkehrendes Element
der Geschichte und das sind durchaus
auch solche Aktionen also in Russland
ist ja immer Autokratie gewesen auch
auch Putin ist ja eine autokratische
Selbstherrschaft wenn man so will nicht
wirklich demokratisch legitimiert nach
unserem Verständnis man gibt sich selber
die macht man gibt sie auch nie wieder
her das ist das uralte Modell russischer
Herrschaft über Jahrhunderte gewesen
unterwechselnden Regimen aber es gibt
auch immer wieder die Auflehnung gegen
diese Regime nicht das zieht sich wie
ein roter Faden durch die russische
Geschichte es gibt immer wieder
Interessengruppen die weil sie andere
Partizipation an der Macht nicht finden
dann sagen die Zentralgewalt muss weg
und wir setzen uns an die Macht das
haben wir
von von großen und sitzen und bei den
bojanen unter Peter dem Großen und bei
pugatschow und es ist ein immer
wiederkehrendes Element russischer
Geschichte im Grunde bisschen zum Kuh
der Bolschewiki dann im geboren 1917 die
sich an die Macht Kutschen wenn die
Zentralgewalt wackelt dann versucht sein
anderer mit Gewalt zu übernehmen ja und
jetzt ist der sprigoshi mit seiner
wagnertruppe der das möglicherweise
versucht das wäre ja aber auch rein
theoretisch diese Situation eine Chance
für die demokratische
Opposition die es ja immer noch zu
teilen in Russland gibt ist die total
zerschlagen oder sehen Sie da vielleicht
eine theoretische Möglichkeit dass die
Leute jetzt auch auf die Straße gehen
und sagen der Ukraine Krieg war schon
war falsch und jetzt schießen wir Russen
aufeinander das ist jetzt erst recht
falsch und wir gehen auf die Straße und
fordern den Kopf von Putin nein das sehe
ich im Moment nicht also die Situation
wir haben wir den Vergleich damals mit
jetzigen angesprochen die Situation war
eine andere die Bürger hatten gemerkt
sie können auch ohne KGB leben sie
können Freiheit leben sie können Wahlen
haben auf einmal merkten die sie haben
was bekommen was sie sich nicht wieder
wegnehmen lassen wollten Putin hat über
20 Jahre seiner Herrschaft alles so
heruntergedreht was dann auch noch
Positionen erlaubt wurde hat das so
wirkungsvoll klein gehauen und
zerschlagen da ist nichts organisiertes
mehr außer diese kleinen Kreise damit
Herrn nawalni und ein paar andere Kreise
noch mehr aber einige Dutzend oder
einige hundert Leute können das nicht
ändern also die Masse der Russen wird
sich jetzt dazu neutral verhalten die
werden den Kopf einziehen und uns sehen
wie sich die Fronten klären ob der alte
Zar der neue ist oder ein anderer Zahn
zu Ruder kommt nicht und die Geschicke
des Landes übernimmt aber man wird sich
da im Wesentlichen raushalten aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach und dann wird
man sehen wie das die bewaffneten Kräfte
da untereinander wir sollten zum Schluss
über die Situation der Ukraine sprechen
des Landwirten nach wie vor und auch in
den letzten 24 Stunden massiv
angegriffen mit Raketen und so weiter
insofern hat die Entwicklung die wir
jetzt in Russland sehen zunächst mal
keine Auswirkung auf das kanns Kampf
Geschehen in der Ukraine oder besser
gesagt gegen die Ukraine wann könnte
sich das ändern
das ist jetzt abhängig davon wieder dank
der Ereignisse in Moskau in Russland
sein wird wenn dieser Putsch in
irgendeiner Weise so weit durchschlägt
dass ist jetzt Kampf gibt der über Tage
oder womöglich sich Wochen erstreckt
dann wird es massive Auswirkungen auf
den Ukraine Krieg haben sollte es
gelingen dass irgendwie an diesem
Wochenende niederzuschlagen dann werden
die Auswirkungen denkbar gering bleiben
aber aber trifft die erste tritt die
erste Variante ein das heißt die Russen
sind eine längere Zeit mit sich selbst
beschäftigt führen mit Gewalt einen
Machtkampf im Inneren des Landes in
ihrem Machtzentrum in Moskau sogar
selbst dann könnte die goldene Stunde
für die Ukraine kommen dann werden die
Russen andere Sorgen haben
vordringlichere sorgen dann wird nicht
sauber und klar geführt werden dann
werden vor allen Dingen auch die Truppen
völlig die motiviert sein weil sie gar
nicht mehr wissen für wen sie dann
kämpfen sollen wer ist denn dann ihre
Regierung die einen oder die anderen und
das alles in einem sinnlosen Krieg dann
gibt es eine Chance dass die Ukraine
diese 70% ihrer Kräfte die sie wohl
bisher noch zurückgehalten hat mit
großen Aussichten ansetzen könnte zumal
mit dem Abzug von
pregorians Wagner Söldner die Truppen
abziehen die ja zum Beispiel bachmut
eingenommen haben und die sind jetzt
quasi abgezogen und die am energischsten
und am fanatischen und am todesmutigsten
gekämpft haben die russische Armee
selber als solche die normale staatliche
Armee hat ja von Anfang an erhebliche
motivationsschwierigkeiten gehabt bei
ihren Soldaten diesen Sinn dieses
Krieges nicht wirklich erkennen und und
diejenigen die ideologisch in absoluten
vernatismus tragen ist natürlich die
wagnertruppe die fährt jetzt im Moment
aus Joachim Weber war das der
Sicherheitsexperte danke dass Sie an
diesem Samstag Abend bei uns im Studio
waren und danke für ihre Einschätzungen
und Analysen sehr gerne ja liebe
Zuschauer das war Phoenix vor Ort mit
unserer Sondersendung Machtkampf in
Russland wir sagen danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit und bis dahin
[Musik]
Russen und Deutsche das ist im 20
Jahrhundert eine Geschichte der
verteilen Bündnisse der echten
Freundschaften und der unerwarteten
Wendungen
diese Beziehung symbolisieren das